hi field this is Sarah from Chicago hey
Sarah from Chicago nice to see you over
there
and Chicago an amazing city in the US
you know a good city where I think you
get a little bit of everything and I met
some beautiful ladies over here in
Chicago and over the years I saved him
on my phone I'll be like Oh Chicago
Janet you know Chicago rain you know
raylene or rain L and then over the
years but then you come back to town
over the years and you think you hit him
up here like I only remember now this
ladies you know she's 45 or 47 and she's
got a couple kids her husband's texting
me back like who the [ __ ] it what's
going on she got to be careful who you
whose number you saved in that great
city let's hear more this morning on my
way to work I was laughing at the
hotline question because my first sexual
experience as a 15 year old was with
them with some cracks rubbing and praise
God babe praise God and let's hear you
just say that part again about the cross
driving because it just makes everybody
heard it I can't tell some with some
cracks rubbing and my boyfriend and I
who is not my husband
we're in the back of my dad's car on her
way home from Great America
oh yeah and so it begins immediately I'm
going back to that place in my heart and
mine right now I want to go put on like
a um I want to put on a big Johnson
shirt they had this special series of
shirts I want to go put you know I want
to I want to put on some old music some
boys to men or some some kind of [ __ ]
and really make it pop so you and your
oh yeah you're in the back and a
parent's car okay let's go my dad's car
on our way home from Great America Great
America is in gurney and you lives all
the way in Chicago so it's a good two
hour drive turn up the music dad three
bar and I remember I just kind of
started
Sheena's crotch and I just don't really
know why oh I know why cuz the Lord
wants you to that's why I mean us look
if you put my hand somewhere and you put
a crotch somewhere else and you turn off
the lights when you turn that light back
on I swear to god boy my handle so let's
hear more I'm the oldest of two brothers
so I didn't really have any siblings
that kind of helped me understand what
sex was what was going to happen none of
that
so he started reacting his view to a
woman touching his crotch and he had a
he had a hard-on for about two hours all
the way from grandma's home and my
husband and I we still laugh about it
but I remember being so shocked by
really understanding what the hell was
going on if he was going to be okay oh
yeah and that's beautiful and you know
that's love when you get erect and
somebody asked you if you're doing okay
I mean that's American love right there
usually you get erect and people woman
might laugh she might you know text to
get a shot of it a snap show her friend
you know Ronnie's got a little dick but
it's beautiful when a woman you know you
get a wreck you've been in a wreck for a
couple hours a girl knocks on the door
hey everything all right let's hear more
now obviously it's something we can look
back and laugh at hanging gang gang a to
our Weiner your man showed out with and
that's beautiful and if you wanted to
enter something in a National 4-h
competition they're judging rabbits and
they're judging you know little
chickadees and stuff you got to have two
of the chickadees and hares got to be
slicked back and they got to be healthy
and their sugar levels good but you show
me a man who can have an erection you
know a two hour wiener owner riding
backseat of a car while his while the
dad is picking the music that's a show
animal to me
thank you for that call and thank you
for that story in just taking me back in
time
I remember hearing the first time I've
ever even heard about people having sex
because we used to do some peeping tom
and when I grew up peeping tom and was I
mean that was cable and we used to do
some good peeping tom and walk and see
somebody eat and I watched somebody eat
or do sex or whatever and it all of it
was kind of the same to me at all just I
was so curious very much like the
American Beauty remember that movie with
Kevin Spacey and the other boy Ben
Affleck or whatever but I loved that uh
I loved watching people live their lives
through pain glass who doesn't and so
what I'm saying now is this I don't even
know what I'm saying I don't you know
i'm talking about but uh but thank you
for that story thank you for taking me
back i remember the first time when I
was young hearing about sex and hearing
that people that were having it and
there was a boy and he was like a year
older than us for two years and
everybody said that he and this girl
that had sex on some lawn chairs out by
a pool over summer
and suddenly everybody's like [ __ ] man
people are scared people are rioting I'm
having sex on pieces of paper and just
drunk just you know it's pinning it to
the shirt remember he's like what are
you talking about you know people didn't
even know like everybody was just
consumed people are buying lawn chairs
and lino laying them just put them in
their yard other people are like
sacrilegious they're buying lawn chairs
I'm like putting gas on them and burning
them yelling racial slurs and stuff at
him it just it got wild but but yeah
once that fire starts once you hear
somebody I mean I remember my buddy my
buddy you know I remember the big thing
was if you could touch a woman's crotch
while y'all were in the back of the car
when the mom was taking you home that
was and still let me say this that is
still a golden move I don't care if
you're 15 or if you are 60 if your wife
or your significant others mother is
driving y'all somewhere and you in the
back with your lady and you get to doing
some touching or you know or they are
your lady jerk you off while your dad is
driving y'all somewhere that's still
awesome man that is still it's kind of
like it's them it's the Mount
Kilimanjaro of sexuality it's just that
rare it's just that thing it's something
it's like so defiant of your parents and
at the same time so like adventurous
because with all your dad has to do is
turn back and look and you are you're
done dude one of my friends who will
name Nate who will remain nameless he
was with his family driving somewhere on
a vacation okay he puts the map up like
this and masturbated behind the map
I mean if you think your parents don't
know that you're masturbating behind a
map in a small vehicle this wasn't an
SUV this is a car SUV
maybe jerking off behind a Rand McNally
[Music]
behind a small map in a car in a siddha
hen whoo dirt that's dirt boy that's
dirt
mm-hmm boy you got to tighten up on that
on that level all right let's take
another story that came in here but the
man just some beautiful stories
beautiful stories and we just wonder
what a phenomenal time this is in
people's lives
well the CIO's cows are you from North
Carolina man called them for the spc FCC
challenge yes sir and that's first time
Krotz touched and that's that F first
time ft CT crotch touch thank you for
calling in Kyle from North Cal lack a
beautiful beautiful place over there and
I know Duke was losing in those in those
to Vanderbilt in those men's College
World Series but kudos to them for for
developing a great program over there I
know you in season in the College World
Series as well right now on whatever you
want to call it at first time crotch
stories first time I grabbed crotch my
parents and everyone else was going to
church and you know when you put the
Lord next to the loans it's a face-off
Oh makes it more exciting doesn't it
when everybody was in church we would
sneak away and go upstairs and we would
swap spit with the girls you know I was
a middle school and I had my girlfriend
at the time and I seen my step sister
and her boyfriend do some I never seen
you and touched her crotch and they told
me that's what you got to do that's what
you gotta do boy
sorry this is a very interesting to me
to hear this research let's hear more
they were older than me so I went back
to Sunday school and I was excited you
know
oh yeah suddenly it's Saturday night
even though it's Sunday school suddenly
it is Saturday night my friend yes sir
let's hear more we have learned this new
trick and we were making out and I
touched your crotch so we get to school
now Monday I'm excited as you know oh
yeah you're damn Wayne Gretzky brother I
mean you're the damn Wayne Gretzky of
young league let's hear it and she has
sent me a note saying we were moving too
fast and she broke up with me
and I'm even grabbing his crotch for a
few years because I was kind of like a
PTSD from you know I thought every time
I try to make a move on anybody they
were gonna break up with me
wow man well appreciate you sharing that
man I couldn't understand that song yeah
you know look that's very look something
happens and then alarms you and then you
set off let's hear more but that's
that's my first cross story so Gang Gang
I love y'all what Gang Gang brother and
thank you for sharing your story with
everybody and I mean that you know it's
brave to put a little bit of yourself
out there whether it's a piece of your
past or a piece of your present and I
and I applaud all of all the callers
that do you know I remember now you know
I had a wrecked-tile dysfunction for
probably bout 11 years and I still
really you know I'm probably still at
all times I gotta have a little bit of
gas station you know some of those GSW
PS as gas station Weiner pills in my
system at all times to even really get
out of bed in the morning I need two
milligrams of something running through
me and and uh and it's uh yeah [ __ ]
sorry for us time out Jesus
man yeah well so you I remember getting
non erect and a lady and then I try to
tell her like I was doing magic and I
was like tada my dick still wasn't doing
erection my Weiner was still being soft
me and you know real natural and she was
disappointed and then I couldn't get
over that for years because really I was
just nervous I should have just said hey
I'm just uncomfortable right now and it
probably would have been cool but at the
time I was just young and I was nervous
and there was broken glass and look I
can't get a reckon your broken glass
okay yeah my bad right but I can't get
erect near broken glass and I still
can't or if there's a car accident or
something do you knife ain't I am ain't
getting the erect near a car accident
okay
yes yeah my bad ladies but yeah those
things really can give you a little bit
of travesty but thank you for sharing
man that is the middle schools a little
young to be learning that trick you know
first time I saw some breasts I remember
I was uh well they used to have somebody
had chiseled some tits into a nice birch
that had been hit by lightning out near
us in the woods and people used to go
masturbate to that and you know and
that's just the Lord working but this
was I was at summer camp and they had
this girl man she had red hair
I'd never seen red hair I've never seen
it I'd seen you know different colors of
hair brown blonde black white
but I'd never seen red hair in this girl
had it managed she just looked so exotic
to me
and I saw him another camp counselor
looking at her breasts one time this
dude Joey I think his name was or you
know Joey was actually a little more
this dude Joey was his name he was my
camp counselor John he had a cousin a
nephew named Jonas oh okay for some
reason I know them and my brain my brain
is just skipping on their name but they
was out I think he grew up out awfully
roid anyway but they Joey I think was
looking at the lady's breast the camp
counselor and I was a camper a camper
and so I was like oh what's in there you
know and she kept looking in her shirt
and and they said oh titties are and so
I wanted to look in right so I looked in
and I saw him dude and I've never seen
titties do to set for my mom's you know
and I'd only sneakily seen them and seen
him sometimes when I didn't want to when
my mom didn't think that we knew what
titties weren't she would on sometimes
she would just get out the bath and we
would seal but what happened was oh oh I
saw him and then I lied I said I didn't
see him and they were like what I was
like yeah I didn't see him you know so
then they let me look again and I looked
again in there and there they were again
still just milling around this see on
this on this camp counselors chest you
know tins and then I said oh I remember
I said I only saw one and that time they
[ __ ] said I was I was like a sicko
and so then I kind of felt like
something's wrong with me after that a
little bit and I was afraid to see both
breasts at once on a woman even though
I'd lied about it I was still like I'll
tell alive on something and then also
suffer the repercussions of my lie
in that crazy I'll be like oh yeah I
only saw one tit even though I saw both
they'll call me a sicko then I feel bad
Lyonne and then I'll also think for
years to come when I see tits and if I
look at both of them at the same time
something Bad's gonna happen to me
so Jesus Christ let's hear another call
that came in but Sunday school slipping
off from the Lord to do the devil's
handiwork
as always the hotline is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three here
we go
this is a first crotch experience call
thank you for the call brother homeward
this is Sean from Boulder City Nevada
Sean o from Boulder City Nevada and I've
never been over there but um you know it
sounds beautiful rolls right off your
tongue Boulder City um I was about 13
between 7th and 8th grade I was prime
touch an area dude that's prime time to
touch a be touched you laying in bed at
night you can just hear other kids
touching each other's crotches and it
just burns you up let's hear more
brother onward it was in Springfield
Missouri
oh yeah this Springfield
go I met this chick at the swimming pool
we go back to her place you know oh yeah
and crotch always feels fresher when
it's right out of the city pool if you
ever noticed that or this summertime
pool the fur or out of a bathing suit
crotch always feels fresher when it's
fresh like that I'll quit interrupting
you homework we go back to her place you
know and to this point I had only really
seen late seventies early eighties
pornography oh yeah sorry I told y'all
wouldn't do that anymore
let's hear the rest of your story sorry
friend babies pornography so you know
I'm a lot of bush back in those days and
so for some reason I thought the little
that JJ was like an inch or two below
the belly button
I guess the hairline of the crotch and
so uh so you thought a woman was like
one of those those little gnomes those
little belt with the jewel in her belly
dang man that's that's very interesting
I mean you would be a very unique
surgeon homeward I was you know
searching around with the old index in
the fingers man I was confused I didn't
know what was going on I didn't know I
[ __ ] around I got hermaphrodite or
something you know I was young but I
finally the girl gave me a little
assistive help you go a little farther
down south and got my i fve never really
talked to her again but uh yeah that was
a high first cross experience set out
Springfield Missouri a public swimming
pools
RIPD Billy conforto we're to keep your
name in the street getting gay gang
Brian thank you for bringing him up man
I appreciate that dude yeah I was
looking at some somebody sent me some
pictures of him the other day actually
and I should put some of those on the
onto the onto the this past weekend and
then we had a shirt designed for him as
well and so they will put that out but
you have a member that did I remember
something like that touching thinking I
was you know I didn't know what that was
just kept pushing on some girl's
midsection that's crazy right just put
this just massage and some girls Fupa or
something who knows I mean it was why
when you were young I had a buddy and
he's to practice
punching girls on his own be whole and
at first I'm like that's crazy but then
I'm like I can't fault this guy like at
least this guy has a little bit of lay
of the land I'm out here wrote you know
you don't know what's going on then I
remember thinking that it was all a myth
that girls didn't even have vaginas cuz
I remember laying now with this one girl
up there off a half-million-dollar road
and that's when you know the pizza
delivery guy had crashed and a lot of
people had robbed him and [ __ ] but I
didn't get involved in that I was back
at the house you know trying to touch a
little light you know trying to just get
involved in that womb tunnel you feel me
get a little into that womb and
[ __ ] I was talking about but but anyway
man thanks for your story man thank you
for calling in brother for sharing that
story let's take another cross story
here we go
hey Theo this is joy from moleska
Georgia just calling in to give you my
first cross touch story hey Julie thank
you for calling in and you know nothing
brings joy to youngsters like touching
one another and and saw it's just ironic
that you called today and thank you for
being a supporter and I'm excited to
come over there to George I'm excited to
get into the South a little bit later
this year on some tour dates and I'm
gonna add some more and I want to find
some VFW chapters where we can go and do
some fundraising at some of those places
but I got a a lot to do let's hear more
thank you for calling Joya I didn't mean
to make that about me for a second let's
go see it's a long time ago because I'm
actually older than you are so but oh
look
crotch stories have no age okay though
these things are timeless let's go I do
remember it vividly because it was the
summer between all the 13 2014 and that
was back in a time where you know little
kids just rode their bikes everywhere
and hung out outside and did everything
all like that during the summer time and
I remember there was probably about ten
of us hanging around on our little bikes
and we had gone to this little area
that's the back of the neighborhood
oh yeah the back of the neighborhood
what goes on back there nothing good and
everything good let's hear more and just
throwing like some blocks and a creek
and stuff these two boys pull up on
their moped and back then you know I
came from an area where oh yeah the
French we call them Frenchmen let's hear
more whoo boys pull up on the moped and
back then you know I came from an area
where that was fancy stuff so the cute
one actually looked at me and he was
like his boys are about 15 that he
looked at me and he was like um hey you
want to ride you want to try riding it
and I'm like oh yeah hell yeah never
been on a moped jumped on the back wrap
my arms around them and we took off
forever
for ya sorry you just got me do you
wanna ride in the backseat Eddie you got
me feeling all of this right now
you know boot scootin boogie you got me
feeling a pass suddenly all of a sudden
let's hear it on the back wrap my arms
around them and we can call now that's
the first time I've ever felt something
you know shaking them between my legs
and stuff like that so already and I've
got these little cute little flimsy bike
shorts on but it was already feeling
kind of crazy plus I got my arms around
this - boy well we hit a bump and all of
a sudden this boy decides to just slide
in his hand take it off one of the
controls slide his hand back behind his
back and just grab ahold of my crotch
now at first I was alarmed but at the
same time it was one of the first time
I've ever had that feeling about do I
like this or do I not so needless to say
I was squealing by the time I got off of
that moped and I guess the moral the
story is I did like it whether I wanted
to admit it at the time or not and
mopeds are fun to ride at times so
anyway that's my first crush story Wow
Wow thank you for sharing that story
it's like that crotch is it's like a
it's like
you ever be in a neighborhood or
something you get to a certain age you
realize oh there's a power plant or
there's like a power grid or area in our
neighborhood or you you drive by that
place for years you don't know what it
is looks like some weird wiring and this
fence is outside do not enter do not
enter and then one day oh that's
electricity that [ __ ] that's that that
place kills monkeys and commercials
years ago and that now that is the
crotch that's that thing that's that
electricity that's that hub that's that
NASA I'm it's all space it's all space
and then you got that NASA just north of
yassuh you feel me that's that crotch
and it's really remarkable it's really
really remarkable to hear that story of
you on a moped a French a French mode of
transportation and the boy reaches back
I mean what a what a Power Move there
and also love how you're not a fit
you're not like oh this got molested
mean that's it nowadays people lose all
of their [ __ ] but the person who is
involved in it they see what's going on
oh I made you know the guy it seemed
like it was just your experience and
that's what happened you could decide if
you liked it or not
you weren't sure it was just a moment
where we kind of decide the guy didn't
you know trap you or nothing like that
or put you in a kennel or anything like
that it was just a regular afternoon and
I bet sometimes you see a moped go by
and you uh I bet those feelings flare up
for you and that's beautiful man it's
truly beautiful to imagine and just to
reminisce and to think about that That's
Life that's life and and I think
it's nice to be able to share his story
and also yeah it's funny cuz that those
thing at those ages things are happening
and we were deciding if we like them or
not do I like this am i okay with this
does this need to stop and this needs to
this needs to occur more what's going on
here
and that's sexuality that's how we
develop some of our sexuality is by
having experiences that are safe enough
where we could still learn and make
choices and and I know some people that
they have dark experiences but I'm glad
that we're sharing ones that are you
know at least ones where we're where we
were all in a space where we could learn
and have a moment of knowledge